and oil refinery burning in southern
Russia local officials say it was hit by
a Ukrainian drone an ante Vladimir Putin
group working in Ukraine freedom of
Russia Legion posted about the attack
but no one has claimed responsibility a
former CIA case officer and Global
Affairs expert says there are many
possibilities including a Russian false
flag operation or Ukraine testing the
waters for a bigger strike either way
the Kremlin May benefit when civilian
targets start getting bombed or blown up
or damaged by drones
that scares people on Tuesday an
apartment Block near Moscow was hit and
two people injured while strikes inside
Russia are rare Ukraine is pummeled
regularly this dash cam video shows
debris from a Russian missile crashing
onto a car Monday in May alone the
capital endured 17 Russian aerosols
leading to praise from Western leaders
this is due to the Ukrainian commitment
and their ability
to be strategic
smart Brave and perfectly well organized
what the streets will look like when the
highly anticipated Ukraine
counter-offensive begins no one knows
but there are fears about the safety of
Europe's largest nuclear power plant we
are fortunate that a nuclear accident
has not yet happened Rafael Grossi
speaking at the U.N security Council
Tuesday proposed five principles for the
protection of the zapparitzia power
plant including no attack on or from the
plant and no heavy weapons such as
multiple rocket launchers be housed
there so far neither side is signed on
crystal gabencing Global News London